votar é um exemplo de óleo 2 500 200
tentar tem pouca conversa perguntas 1 da
instituição do músico jackson em música
e cidadania é e ventos fortes em seus
estádios e da educação ambiental nós
identificarmos o que estamos a estudar
esta inclusive e tv que não solta está
ocupado com 35 cento de área florestal
parece pouco na europa há anos atrás era
mais 400 entradas 200 anos atrás era
cerca de 10% marítima nós as nossas
florestas
depois de comprados e isso vamos este
valor 35 c
o que significa que há sempre uma
solução para o problema
vamos ver que atualmente isso é o
principal
queria ficar nossa paisagem da europa
que nos últimos dez anos entre 2003 2003
foi o único que não conseguiu inverter a
tendência dos outros pisos de crédito de
caneta que traz tentamos retribuir a
ausência do isaaa fato trágico é
importantíssimo que nem se lançar no
verão quente e seco é
sim existe fome nem tanto os outros
países têm o mesmo clima no ct confirmou
mais cinco ingressos que nós conseguiram
diminuir
é a área vida e nós não nós conseguimos
reduzir conseguinte estados humanas
aumentar esta área e vai escoar 2017
antes perderam em r 103 mil infectados
da nossa floresta
quase um quarto da nossa estado
agora vou utilizar alguma comparação que
não teve surpresa que nos olhos
vamos ter enquanto os fatores
multiplicar sorrir aos não tivesse em
2023 é ficavam sem floresta 14 ter em
conta as metas políticas gostar que ora
estão já em curso foi uma reação a este
cantasse exemplo ninguém ter morrido se
não tiver ficamos sem floresta bom
principais concelhos afetados foram
consegue coimbra zona centro do doente
com a saúde de viseu castelo branco e no
norte do distrito de viseu central
o norte que os peritos entraram em
consenso e vamos ver quem é capaz de
produzir tal onde estaria em condições
mais favoráveis porque não conhecia
também está aí com os últimos cem anos
conheceu um aumento maior da floresta
floresta floresta numa cultura
principais causas são intencionais foi
negligência
alguns ressentimentos muito e apenas 2%
causas naturais
pensas que causa foi uma causa natural
então realmente não gosto dessas coisas
quantas vezes a gente se passa por cima
de telejornal um jornal sobre política
economia é muito importante para ajudar
muito pouco em educação ambiental é
ambiental principal no início de uma
história
enquanto que não conhecia os livros é
uma grande falha como jovens é o quarto
no grid e também do norte tem sulamérica
encontra em um casal do tua
instrumentação mesmo caminhada nos
perguntaram como ela joga fu dj filme
era a nossa paisagem online no inverno
tinham no verão era totalmente diferente
perguntar posso deixar você percebeu o
de volta na nossa paisagem como esta
aqui no estado
os flashes anos na floresta emendando
não nessa floresta tem uma paisagem foi
importado de outros países e atualmente
a monocultura
então nós tivemos as causas e escalas
para uma pedra desta biodiversidade que
algumas espécies da nossa floresta nos
olhos
alguns clientes fruto foram utilizados
em tempo muito primitivos para fazer pão
para aquecer o homem em outras coisas
a intenção do mel e temos uma paisagem
sede do clube que tem medo desse filme
que é fundamental e nós também temos que
saber gerir instauração de filhos ficam
em inserir as nossas necessidades num e
alimentado
mas o consolo são limitados
não temos de ter muita atenção de então
é aproveitar todos os benefícios da
margem altamente inflamável como podem
ver nessa nesta imagem no formato é que
não habitar para outros animais
o único ser vivo que esse alimento do
comité a ilha do mel pois somos nós os
alimentamos a transmitir diretamente nos
dá uma fonte de rendimento não é o papel
de tudo o que é privado podendo as
causas também sabem fingir que é
essencial que também que nós não
conseguimos quantificar terminar as
coisas que nos dão principalmente as
pessoas foram retiradas com à água
potável à prevenção de cheias de
captação de dióxido de carbono do que
nossa floresta capta mais novo de
poluição industrial como seria o nosso
país consegue captar mais do que temos
de ter em conta que cerca 2.000 a partir
daí a atribuir um valor não conseguimos
pagar com os nomes das florestas são
desconhecidas são muitos
isso não tem um valor para receber
muitas vezes abandonam floresta e nós
temos cerca de 400 mil proprietários do
estádio
temos 98% propriedade privada com o stal
e apenas 2% do estado de 2 por cento do
que a média europeia é de 40 e 60
lugares chegando perto dos 87 por cento
na frança
penso não quero dizer que quase 50% dia
muito loco da floresta
bom então eu vou citar aqui nós vemos as
causas porque queremos fazer para
inverter esta situação não vou citar
aqui em
um pensador filósofo muito mais
inclusive este século 19 um brinquedo
que os ctt qo não só pelo ambiente
eu não sou bastante inquieto não se
sintam se optado tanta alegria do título
do teste da vontade que eu fui em várias
universidades nos estados unidos em 1850
em 1961 e eu tive um sonho que ela possa
gostar da natureza
vou passar três anos no time com três
por 39 metros quadrados que o próprio
construiu agora um absurdo livro mas
construiu escrever um livro sobre
desenvolvia civil porque não concordavam
costa votou nos estados unidos mas
fundamentalmente do jogo por causa do
gelo 3 é que o fábio fundamentado e eu
desisti cresce roma inglaterra tirava o
sustento das florestas primitivas havia
certo em um sol de experiências se ele
subir em um só você escolhe o próprio
futuro do homem que respirava de uma
missão do sol está exaurindo extra sala
e conferindo os ossos passagem do tempo
que isso possa acontecer no nosso país
agora parece um livro monopolizando a
carta de caçador e pensamos que estão
livres nos jogos nesta noite em 1986 e
que o nosso papel aqui tem que ser a
questão ambiental fip mais pessoas
ambiental foi meu pai não foi levar uma
casa do estado né
resultado nova mídia suportável civil
fazia a linha contará histórias não é
que eu tenha jantado do verificado em
temas em duas sessões fantásticas
não tem curso só assim como esta
província que vocês vêem que ele se tudo
sobre as espécies do seu habitar
como é que só podiam depois mais tarde
fiquei com uma enorme paixão pela
natureza e do contraditório
você se encontra bastante quando ela
mais estranha porque pra dizer a ninguém
que é o elenco hoje sexta é a torre na
altura em que o que nossa escola o que a
escola pode fazer começou a nossa escola
verde é de pensões do deus da educação
ambiental encontrou pouca coisa encontra
coisas tensas com muito pouco muito
pouco interesse
assim o programa de um livro em que
vocês já vão para aquelas metas de todos
em fazer o exame e você está em muitas
vezes nós estamos muito para os anos e
assim nós mandamos nada significam
inteiro que ela aprendizagem ficou
conspirado e na educação ambiental que
existem segundo serem presidente quer a
continuidade de tempo durar a nossa
metrô ambiental e ecológica nas falas é
suficiente então eu fiz um e querem nos
basear em dados não quizer minha opinião
diferente milhões e foi o inquérito com
poucas frutas e em principais conclusões
é que o sono ser um pouco mais modestos
falso em florestas dos incêndios conhece
um pouco mais esforços pães que
apresentaram
elas possibilitam problema porque estava
uma potencial humano e nós tivéssemos um
aumento com que o trio o inter se
passava porque essa atuais seus
problemas
então vamos ver que tem 400 anos de pena
e 24 ficaram ter vários estudos nas
imagens de 1 15 mas só tem um tempo
limitado e restrito que era um frasco de
apenas 300 atletas e até um dos mais
comuns na nossa floresta existe a nossa
mata que o autor de apenas 900 animals
lhes que é um curso que existe no parque
nacional dos direitos que já observava
tem apenas por 34 60 mil para o super
especial que ela viajava no carro não
temos pessoalmente frente seguinte e
estava na europa estilos que é uma
batalha que eu nunca vi que consegui ver
temos 15 dos seus pois o entre os dias
20 e 28 mãe
temos opções é e que preocupam os alunos
não saibam conviver em uma espécie em
extinção e muitas pessoas não
identificadas o tamanho do ensino e da
imagem de silvério não ia ficar
depois temos guias outras opções
usando parte muitas pessoas significar o
torres como sendo uma fazenda e à
montante totalmente diferente
outros dados dos dois meses quanto tempo
eles passarão a resultar na maior parte
apenas um dia e depois 20 a 60
não passarão de número 483 de neve de
800 foi apenas um dia e fez questão de
passar muitas são as principais
atividades que os outros pensavam que
ganhar os dois times fizeram e nós
precisamos calar os quatro projetos
sobre os quais já têm a sua fauna flora
e 35 133 onde eu podia pesquisa por
acaso está no ano nós iremos suspenso na
hora vídeo front todos os que estão mais
bem classificada no nível do estado do
tempo 9 - e também consegue aliar isso o
desenvolvimento econômico da china de
campo então temos aqui que o centro de
aprendizagem e educação ambiental são
sentidos
só depois vai às ações
o as regras ou parte mais significativa
do tecido sem ciência nós vamos
conseguir resolver muitos problemas do
cliente
depois outro inquérito em 2009
aprendendo a fazer pois claro que só não
sobrepõe às outras na parte prática ea
parte estava manhã começava na cidade
tem começado não ser conhecido e com
isso fazer a em 2012 morta numa partida
de suspensão como meu pai às vezes e
anímico giz de gesso reais de controle
fundiária em nota
amy fundiária exatamente por causa dos
mesmos usados são inusitados e do então
esse público com 100 kg de açúcar e
muita ação dos próprios planos que
aconteceu em dois nós não dirigido criei
este passo o uso do 1º ciclo vão alguns
dos sucessivos e com isso fizemos
algumas entidades
bom vou terminar que quero é que a
natureza é consultor magnetismo e sem
consentimento gm saiu de algum aos
nossos passos e nós muitas vezes nos
enfrentaria são os seguintes do caminho
certo mas não deu certo tempo subiria
abstração
a seguir o que me invade a função de
pessoas da escola que vocês se não
quiser terminar como instituição música
de um dos crimes no nova estrutura só
que eu não vou gostar porque você tem
juízo
obrigado